so we guys doing well I'm here at
brother Bashir's house as you guys know
the provides spoke to windows making
first about Tom Robinson I'm here in
front of his house why am I here because
as you guys know yesterday Tony Robinson
chased him down the road the guys
mention the guy not mentally well he's
suffering from a mental illness his
sisters here he was going to testify to
that he was chased down that road over
here he fell on the floor he goes up out
of fear and questioning he said that Ali
Dawa brainwashed me yeah firstly myself
and you guys know exactly that I'm not a
preacher I'm against the oppression and
for him saying that you can clearly see
he's not mentally well if he was
mentally well would not even say the
things the fresh that he made against
Tony Romo said they assisted here
star-making system yeah so just quickly
I don't refuse well do you know your
brother got chased down yesterday
no you didn't know okay okay can you
just briefly tell us is he medically you
know it's a Sisyphean yeah this is he
medically like this he's medically unfit
he's medically unfit yeah okay all right
so um why do you think he sent that you
know he said okay I need a brain watch
me even though I was with him like last
night so can the chicken plate that's
why I wanted to meet him he said he was
something I've got him some food and I
spoke to him and I said look do not meet
these friends it's not good but
yesterday why do you think because you
said to me he did not take his
medication okay is this does he react
back this man hasn't seen some
medication when he doesn't take his
medication he doesn't always saying half
the time
speaks Russian Anissa all the symptoms
of schizophrenia
okay all right so do you think why do
you think he said I did our promotion
probably out of fear because probably
out to pee okay cuz there was no
neurology he's obviously no man sir
yeah has he has he done this before that
would be putting people before he really
yeah um yeah he has
and you own feminism okay
so just and we also said just briefly
that your mother's not well because of
this whole situation yeah okay so guys
as you can see because no one home to
sister longest I'm even embarrassed to
come here at this time but because of
what's happened and you guys know Tony
Robinson he's gonna take advantage of
the situation and most you guys know but
just to make it clear I came to this
Peter his younger sister and his mother
because of what's happened and told me
chasing him down etc because of that his
her mother is in the hospital so now
Tony Robinson released the address of
this house yeah we just want to urge
people and say look the guy is not
mentally well so do not do the same
thing what happen was Baron Osborn who
went in ran over him and FISMA Park do
you not take matters into your own hand
because of what Tony Robinson said and
come here and causing damage more to the
family sister forgive me for disturbing
you guys may Allah bless you and a
brother sisters as you can see the
following clips are about to play will
show you the clear-cut context when I
met him when he messaged me and the
precautions that I took of getting the
police involved even though he's not
mentally well bought it's a friend still
and what I did you can watch that now
sister thank you very much Marilyn
so now Monica what am I talk about okay
oh brother this isn't dear friends hope
he doesn't do well welcome to my channel
and I think eyes know recently what
happened is there is this person called
Abdul Bashir if I'm not mistaken who has
done a video threatening Tony Robinson
and his family's life saying that he
wants to kill his kids and they start
now I first went to see the video which
you see for yourself in a minute is that
it doesn't seem mentally right he
doesn't seem mentally stable but when I
saw that video on the table mrs. page
I realized that that
night midnight somebody messaged me
saying the same things which you see on
the video let's just watch it for us so
yo Tommy I challenge you and all of your
people to a stabbing match to killing
much I weigh 115 kg seventeen point five
inch biceps 15 chest almost but cruel
not true bodybuilder you don't know me
if you take a single breath I will kill
your family and you will eat your family
now as I saw there he's basically making
this claim of let's have a stabbing
match it doesn't seem like someone
normal do you get it like it's like it's
all normal
so when he was saying about my biceps
and this star was that hot on the second
this guy someone on similar message me
on Instagram so I went to my Instagram
and I saw and I was like this is the
same guy so what happened is after OCC
Tony Robinson right he saw he was
getting the police involved etc no
problem and after that he said that he
wants he will give a thousand pounds to
anybody that will find this guy so
obviously I thought look besides the
money I don't want the money I don't
need the money I don't keep your money
yeah okay if there's one thing that I
want were tolerance in the debate and
which he's been running away from after
he got exports on the phone call so
since then he's been hurt he's been
trying everything he's been accusing me
that I leaked his address when it wasn't
me is an absolute lie and then basically
what happened next is this guy was
tweeting more videos even messaging him
like really disgusting message which
I'll show you in the spring as you can
see that I'm gonna stab you I'm gonna
you know cut your mom's there whatever
I'm gonna do this and then and so you
can see from his language he's not
mentally right yeah so yesterday I went
to work and I told I told him I went to
work and I got a message from Tony
Robbins and saying call me enough okay
it's maybe it's regarding this issue yet
it was issued in the meantime I message
this guy and I said to what you're doing
is disgusting you don't threaten
people's families he'd never get
families members involved and I was
having a go at him and telling him
clearly you can't do this
stop him yeah and I said give me your
number your address wherever I'm gonna
come and see you so that day when I was
at work yesterday
Tommy said call me
so it's not gonna call him I called him
but you can hear the conversation for
yourself what not conversation yeah and
I thought he's calling me to discuss
this matter of this guy yet but he's
thought messaging me calling me saying
on the phone call what you here for so
that um you said you're gonna come to my
house number eight I'm like what the
hell are you talking about nothing this
this isn't the conversation yeah this is
the conversation that happened Tommy
Tommy okay okay I'll listen to you you
listen to me Oh I'm listen to hunt can
we live we live is no important to me
I'm not I'm not going to your house I've
never said I'm gonna go to your house
okay listen listen listen listen to me
listen to me I've heard you I've said
too even on the phone call Tommy I know
where you live but I'm not gonna come to
your house I said I won't see Tommy
sorry I I never I never said your
address and I never will you know what
cuz I'm not you I would never ever
listen listen Tommy Tommy listen okay
no I'm not listen I thought you wanted
to me to speak to you because of this
other guy that I'm meeting today who's
been threatening you
I thought you'd call me because of that
I don't know what the hell that guy he's
been threatening you
he's been saying he wants to kill your
family this that he's mentally unstable
I'm seeing him today he was messaging me
I'm seeing him because he messaged me
two days before and I realized what he
said to you by his biceps he sent the
same message to me and I spoke to him
and I said your room what the hell are
you doing did he see my messages I'm
going to see him today I'm ringing him
to make a video so he can do a public
apology and he's literally he's mentally
unstable anyway so I'm doing a video
sorry come do you need to be a doctor to
see some he's messaging me saying I'm
stronger than this person look at my
biceps does he look like a mentally
stable person to you
he's no no I know
of course of course
I know that's why that's why I to me to
me to me I'm not gonna get one thing
straight
I will never ever if I knew I saw where
you lived I will not come to your house
that's not gonna happen you know why cuz
I'm not you now point number two this
guy listen listen to me listen this
other guy who's fit into your life I
know you're right just got he's mentally
stable doesn't mean we just bypass and
be like oh it's okay no because this guy
can actually carry this out so therefore
I'm gonna go see him and say listen mate
what you said is wrong yeah you're
either mentally unstable which I'm gonna
assess myself when I see him because
he's sending me weird messages like my
biceps of my choice yes I have I have I
don't I don't agree prevent a forget
prevent I'm totally against permit and
magic Nawaz is nobody
Timmy Maginot is not even a Muslim to me
number one yes met see see I tagged him
on my post I said I reported two times
on your profile and on mine because it's
a serious offense so therefore I'm gonna
make I'm gonna be in today if you wanna
meet him
do you wanna me crap I'm gonna I'm
ringing him he's not picking up when I
when wherever he's gonna be made okay
okay I'm gonna ring you after fight guys
he's talking about number two son I
shall be quiet and prevent although what
what you talk about from it yeah I you
can see on my Twitter messages here I at
it met Metropolitan Police to be
informed about this guy because he's
mentally ill but still there's not give
him a right to say those words because a
lot of people who are mentally unstable
like Tommy said on a phone call can
carry out the act so I said no problem
and I got the permission police leave
off and I said Tommy look I won't find
you this guy I don't want you thousand
plus q father but I don't know no penny
for me I don't do this for the money
yeah okay
and everybody knows that I'm not
threats punching this that physically
even no I just want in discussion that's
what I'm known for
but Tommy's been trying his best calling
me jihadi all this nonsense yeah I said
we will go and find this guy all I want
from this once we find it sorted out he
apologized you you see that the guy's
not mentally right we'll leave it at
that and I were gonna vada baked
that's what I said yeah however he said
call me back later at the start I
messaged him you can see clearly here I
said look I'm Tony I'm glad to see in a
p.m. are you gonna come didn't come I
said no problem
anyways I left my house and went all
doing that I went all the way there saw
this guy as soon as I saw him I shaped
his hand and he starts saying this have
a unrwa know from that moment I knew
he's not okay he's not right in the head
you know and may Allah give him guidance
and help his help him in his affairs
wherever it may be
so I think it's got chicken college when
chicken cottage and he start picking on
other people now cause I've stopped it
on his idea I said I'm hungry he said no
he said I'm hungry I've got my chicken
burger some few wings and we sat down
and I said to him look and the stand
cause is mentally unstable I stood just
in his head don't do that I said don't
do these videos you can't threaten
people's lives I even made the video
there how can I show you let's go to the
video quickly yeah ok guys hope you guys
doing well I'm here in South London as I
promised I came to see a blue bus area
why because we fight hatred wherever it
comes from
yes no matter if it's from a Muslim
non-muslim Chinese green blue you don't
know whatever color you are hatred
preaches more hatred and innocent people
suffer now I'm here with Abdul Bashir
which I came to South on a specifically
to see him a long journey because I live
up north no fronting so he's here no no
don't give you a dress yeah so after
brushes here
I just want wanting to be clarified yet
what do you suffer for me
[Music]
schizophrenia yeah this is this what
yourself from here okay do you have a
medical report yeah yeah okay now I want
to come to something yeah okay
now what you said was wrong you accept
that yeah okay now I would personally
say even though I disagree with Tommy
yeah I believe he's a liar he's a hate
preacher but that does not give you a
right yeah
she threatened his family his kids his
children it bust his name yeah or
Buster's name whatever it may be
threatened behavior so do you apologize
for in them yes okay you do do you mean
that and you're not gonna do it again
yeah it's hard
it's like stabbing myself to apologize
and I apologize so yeah you know what
because we have to be Shifu - uh Sophia
and this is not an act I don't I don't
know this guy did do I know you when did
you message me plus yesterday yes all
right yesterday before he messaged Mia
the same message so as you can see he's
suffering from a mental disorder he
admitted himself what he said I'm very
sure because his love was suffering
however Tommy uses this and I'm not
saying like if he came and said you know
what what he said what this guy said was
wrong and I'm here to confront him and
say it was wrong however the way Tommy
is making it seem like he's bringing it
to Islam and saying Ally radicalized him
this is an outright lie
Tommy just cuz you radicalize people
that Darren was one don't think
everybody's the same he's apologized
you're not gonna do it again yes okay so
we're going to leave it at that
Tommy you supposed to come here you up
offered a thousand pounds to anybody
that that will find this guy yeah I
messaged you and I said look I will find
him
yeah I will find him and speak to him
and he and he will apologize I'll make
him apologize to you he's suffering from
an altered mental disorder yeah just
quickly just let me finish it
sir let me finish it so therefore I
don't want you thousand pounds I said to
you only one condition
you come you see and then after you see
man you saw out meaning you have a
debate then we have a discussion you did
not come you don't come so just finish
off Simon yeah so that's why it's very
clear to me to me and I'm gonna leave
like that that you are an absolute
coward and you're a liar and you know
your lies gonna be exposed that's what
you don't want to meet me
you know and sanon I'm sure finally all
your photos can see that yeah we can see
tell me you want to meet me me mean that
chicken cottage entertain no one's me to
no one yeah okay you're gonna stop that
behavior Robinson you leave Tom Robinson
to me but I was it something good
something good but nothing you're not
gonna do nothing like that yeah okay
okay yeah all right because okay because
why because this lamb doesn't teach us
this okay oh it's none you should never
ever innocent people should never
threaten anybody okay guys it's very
clear to you we would fight heat
wherever it is whoever it is from you
our job is to have discussions
intellectual discussion okay not you
know shout abuse verbal abuse I'm gonna
kill you I'm gonna do this know about
that do you get it so therefore it's
very clear hope you guys have benefited
and understood our point of view and
stop taking advantage of people like
this to further your agenda by saying
it's time to do this all this rubbish if
you're a man enough stick to your words
and come and debate me cuz you know you
get destroyed every single verse bring
me every single verse you you want but
you don't want to work out so guys take
care
so the video are clearly sent to him
that is wrong yeah I don't know this guy
from Adam I don't know who he is yeah
anyways he said he watches my video how
many guys video Musa at Nan's video no
problem and I watched our videos on our
videos nowhere nowhere have we ever
claimed to harm an insect never yeah
okay so weapons this this morning I see
a video where Tony Robinson has gone in
front of this guy's guy's house waiting
for him yeah have you got mental health
issues yeah alright so you're talking
about killing more kids however I found
you before the police have found you
however I got you here before the police
found where you run into you little [ __ ]
wait you wanna sleep wait good listen
gap I'm not gonna hurt you I'm not gonna
hurt you stand up I'm not gonna hurt you
I'm not gonna hurt you you're
threatening to murder my children but
I'm not gonna hurt you okay
you wonder how you had already hurt you
okay I'm not gonna hurt you you're
threatening to murder my children how do
you think brother if you've got mental
health issues you need help brother if
that's the case if you're standing in
front of me now yeah if you are you
gonna come to my house and hurt my
family law so why are you signing a kid
someone could bring
someone's brainwashing you I can tell so
much brain whose brain mushroom I lead
our elite I was brainwashed shoot to
kill my kids Annie Bryan a li de zhua
has brainwashed you oh I [ __ ] knew it
rough I [ __ ] knew it roughly if
you've got don't be scared cuz I'm you
know how to plan something all in my
life of what torment and notice I'm not
can see see meeting you now I know
there's no danger to my family yeah okay
I'll protect you I'll protect me he goes
the chases the guy that falls on the
floor he picks it you got it up and he's
kid you can see from his face the guy
skip because I had a break I get
brainwashed yeah and he goes oh who but
he goes I need ow
yeah okay now I just want you guys had
business here this guy is freaking Tony
Robinson his mom his children his kids
any man would lose his mind
no problem he totally ignores he says
you know what you're not mentally right
he dismisses all the fish that he's made
about his life but when he said I got
brainwashed for an adult it's that
serious
what does that show you obviously you
guys know he's trying his best to Frodo
me because I know he's got people
watching me I know he's got people going
through my criminal records see if we
can sleep and there's nothing there
I'm clean so that's why with me it's
another ball game with me he knows Ali
now that's not gonna get physical yeah
that's not good for me because I need
him to hit me so I can say jihadi I need
I wasn't gonna do that house career
record is clean you know he's not
involved in fraud anything like that oh
my gosh
let me check social media social medias
clean what we're gonna do so therefore
he dismisses the guy friend his family
says he's mentally ill but look at this
inconsistency but when the guy said I
was I knew it I knew it he was and then
he goes I need our has been brainwashed
this guy to kill my family
I'm the same guy who's been chasing this
guy finding this guy to where he lives
and called you to come because what he
did his room but to me my message this
dude yeah and for you guys I know you
guys seen Ali profanity why you keep
chasing him he's a coward this wanna me
brothers this guy has to be exposed and
he's gonna be exposed problem sisters
yeah and he is from this desperation to
me it makes me want to catch him even
more you know why because you can see is
going through anything to avoid me and
he's really scared my message is this my
next videos gonna be me and Tommy
the face in sha Allah if Allah would
follow them no more tweets understand
I'm leavin with that next video is going
to be me and Tommy Robinson face to face
inshallah only feel that gonna believe
that rubbish is this fun of us yeah make
dua my next video is gonna be confronted
on rubbish and all his lies what is nice
is going to expose one by one he's been
lying to people but my religion and I'm
gonna confront him okay so as far as I
know for sure he's here because he's
arrested he's in a police station
they're assessing if he's really
medically mentally ill or not so
therefore my even go to the police
station just to see that what's gonna
because we do really want to speak to
myself but inshallah like I said the
police is dealing with the matter
do not take matters into your own hands
and come across trouble for this family
I think they going